when you speak of Ava Gardner you have  to start by admitting that mother nature  certainly lingered over the job miss  Gardner is most assuredly one of the  town's handsomest people but more than  that she is a young actress of  considerable skill she is with us  tonight to present the awards for  distinctive achievement in documentary  production ladies and gentlemen miss Ava  Gardner  nominees for the best feature length  documentary are the quiet one near  bursting Janice lo producer the secret  land the United States Navy  metro-goldwyn-mayer oh oh da producer  now mr. Francis Hall for the price  waterhouse the magic envelope if you  please  the secret land United States Navy  the following a nominated for the Best  Documentary short subjects  heart-to-heart fact film organization  Herbert Morgan producer operation  vittles United States Army Air Force  toward independence United States I the  weather is toward independence United  States our  thank you very much miss gone